five years after the murder of her
sister joe cox kim ledbeter is batley
and spends new mp
morning love
he may not have voted for her but plenty
did
she's grateful and i'm very very proud
of the work that we've all done together
so thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
and so is her boss what a fantastic
victory
and a very narrow one too after a bitter
and divisive campaign
labour holding off the conservatives by
just 323 votes
a tiny margin but a big moment for a
leader desperate to arrest a
miserable nationwide decline today
is a really important start for us labor
is back in terms of labour being back
your detractors would say that this is a
victory for kim
that she is the local candidate and she
saved your skin
and actually this is not about kirstar's
leader this is about kim this is not
your victory this is a victory for the
whole labour movement and i've had
messages from across the united kingdom
this morning and it has filled
everybody's hope parts with
hope that actually those values those
core labor values
can win out and they will win out but
labor barely won
losing votes to the conservatives into
veteran campaigner george galloway
who stood here to defeat labour and
forced kierstarma out of his job
the conservative party chair conceding
matt hancock's rule breaking
and resignation may have played its part
you know we fought a really hard
campaign i'm really disappointed and
particularly disappointed for ryan
um but you know at the end of the day
you know this wasn't a great result for
labour
you have to concede that the behavior of
your former health secretary must have
had
some impact on people in batley and spen
who are honest hard-working people
and don't like the way he behaved so you
know it was something that came up on
the doorstep i have to be honest about
that
for kim ledbeter pure joy that she
managed to hold her late sister joe
cox's buttly and spend
seat for labour by the thinnest of
margins and for kierstarma huge relief
that she saved the seat and saved his
own skin
calls for his resignation are muted for
now at least
but labour are still in big trouble the
trend
is downwards the tories ran them so very
close
sir kia stamos says labour is coming
home but the big question now is whether
he can take this
win and use it to revive his stuttering
leadership
this result a reprieve for sarkia but
still
so much work to do beth rigby sky news
batley and sven